all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel put a
one in the chat if you can hear me one
in the chat I want to make sure I'm live
make sure I'm
going so please let me know in the chat
um also guys oh
wait please please consider we are
demonetized so if you want to fund the
show if you wanna if you like what I
have to say or even you dis like what I
have to say please read a cash app or a
venmo if I get your cash app or your
venmo during the show I will read it
um yeah if if I get a cash up or a venmo
during the show I'll read it I'm G to
try to do this every like half hour you
know please bear with me while we work
out the Kinks of being demonetized we're
trying to make it work anyways so hello
guys hello hello how are you let me know
in the chat how you are one if it's a
good day two if it's a bad
day lot of let's see lot of good days in
the chat bad days where's
Auntie okay yeah Auntie Jenny was here
the other day um we're filming a
documentary that she was a part of it
was really great to see her you know
everyone said me and Auntie had beef
we're just beefing all this
stuff no beef no beef don't listen to
the TM
reaction channel news okay and and
that's the thing I I
found that people get very triggered
nowadays and I think I just have that
effect where I just know how to trigger
a
[__] I Pearl is just you know the CEO
of triggering trigger trigger trigger
okay so today I touched
on
today I touched on a topic that really
does trigger people it really does and
that is religion and what I found with
religion is that the same tactics when I
criticize women there there's a couple
responses that I tend to get not all
women are like
that even if there's a general Trend
with women you can't say oh women are
like that no no no you're the bad guy
die the same thing with church if I say
hey the church people are going downhill
I had a tweet that
really triggered people and I never
thought that I could trigger people that
much just with my opinion especially
church people because you think they're
more based more grounded but I really
thought back to my life and I thought
about the most kind selfless things that
people have done for
me and I thought about
if those people were religious or
not and guys if I'm being
honest the best people I know the
kindest most self obviously my dad is
one of them my dad's not overly
religious but even outside of him I
think back and I think why is it that
the church people don't have a better
reputation than the rest of the
population similar to women they have
great
marketing and great shaming tactics if
you don't think that they are what they
say they are for example if I say modern
women are selfish entitled and
damaged even though across the board
that is true you will get women
screaming that not all women are like
that you will get women
screaming that you are the bad guy for
pointing that out and when I say that I
don't notice a difference between the
kindness and compassion from church
people than I do with the rest of the
population everybody screams and cries
at me like it's my fault the reputation
that you guys have
built how how is this what did I do to
what did I do I just existed and said my
experience and then church people will
argue tooth and nail screaming that my
experience isn't real
okay all
right that's fine
never any
humility or
consideration Christian women are so bad
that many men consider a red flag to be
a Christian woman many men say watch out
for CH Christian women because they are
worse than the general population of
women and you know this experience
actually I it I'll tell you what backed
it up you know being in the show I hear
things from behind the scenes I know a
lot of things that you guys guys don't
know I'm not the type to ever to ever if
out someone for something they told me
behind the scenes okay I believe you
build trust whatever I wouldn't I
wouldn't go that
way
but I found that so many men would say
that men are evil horrible people if
they cheat and those were the same guys
screwing all the chicks I swear this
happened to me so many times where I'd
be on a show and I would get so I would
get so annoyed I'll give you an example
one guy said cheating is evil that is
that is you're a bad man if you cheat
and I argued with him and I said look I
don't think it's the worst thing ever I
don't think it's the end of the
world this man and his girlfriend had
three
sons I mean I guess it's not technically
Che you
know Pearl Pearl hears things you
interview a thousand people people talk
people tell you who they're dating who
they're talking to so me I just try to
live in reality now again my morality I
try to take my morality out of it and I
can't tell you why I feel this way maybe
it's
just I feel weird using God as a brand I
know that most people watching are not
the same religion as me I know that the
culture isn't necessarily religious and
I feel quite odd at times
saying you know I I just find it weird
you know I I can't tell you why I feel
this way but I've never felt like your
religious your relationship with God is
something that should be for public
display I've always felt like it was a
private thing maybe maybe that's that's
just my personal opinion you know um but
it it because when I find that people
make it a public thing it almost becomes
a show and again many times many
times you you don't
necessarily you can feel when things
become a
show and there's no way to really
quantify it or measure it but I remember
having this feeling like early on in
church um when that something was just
off and I couldn't figure out why it was
off
okay so let's let's okay let's let's
start
so sorry I'm backtracking a little bit
I'm getting ahead of
myself okay so the church has bigger
fish to fry than high value men cheating
women find 80% of men unattractive
ugly or not at all desirable meaning
that 80 80% of men are not sleeping
around there is a very small percentage
of men that even have the opportunity to
run through chicks it is an exception it
is not the rule and yet what tradcons
have spent all week doing is wasting
time telling the Leonardo DiCaprio of
the world stop running through these
chicks when really the conversation
would should be with the women to stop
sleeping with the Le stop sleeping with
men that are clearly never going to
commit to you you know thinking that you
can tweet men and to stop having
sex with a bunch of chick chicks is
equally as delusional as thinking you
can tweet women into not having sex with
the top men they just seem to find each
other okay I I don't know what to tell
you and what I've seen is Chase this
week went and attacked myON and I'll
tell you what myON used to trigger me
early on he really did um you know he
would say things and I thought he was
harsh or rude and I I really I wasn't
the biggest fan and and the longer I
listen to him the more I realized he's
actually one of the few guys that tell
the truth the other guys are pandering
the other guys are telling you what you
want to hear and I realized this because
sometimes when I say something that's
uncomfortable like I say that men and
women in the church are not of a higher
moral quality than out of the church I
get so many people they attack my faith
they attack my family they they just go
after me and even though that's true I
know that's true I've been alive for 27
years I've been involved in many
different types of churches and I've
interacted with church people and
non-church people I don't see a
difference and what I realized is myON
was saying things that hurt your
feelings a bit if you see my um I went
on his show like three years
ago and I argued I
said high value men don't she and I
thought he was just talking [__]
but then I interviewed a thousand
people and I really looked at the world
and I tried to be as honest as I could
without my personal feelings getting
into
it and he was right men not dorks with
money that's different dorks with money
don't cheat but men that typically have
the ability to pick up
women tend to sleep with
multiple they might go a time period
without but usually it is hard for men
to Turn Down Easy sex it just is and if
you're a chick and you're married to a
guy that is that guy which most of us
won't be I mean let's just be honest
most women will not get that guy but if
you do I think it's easier to just
accept that that might happen rather
than go looking for problems it might
happen and it's not the biggest deal men
and women view sex differently men can
have sex and not care about a woman
women it is not the same this is not to
say it is morally
okay
but I mean this is the way of the world
and women it's so funny because these
Church women have such a high they're on
such a high horse they think they're
better than everybody and they'll go
around lecturing these men about
sleeping around when what were they
doing at 22 95% of women are not virgins
on their wedding nights so they too also
had sex with multiple men
so it's a bit hypocritical and that's
what I want to talk about right now the
hypocrisy in the church is crazy it is
crazy crazy crazy now I know everybody
is a hypocrite and I do I do I would
like to separate I know you can say that
a sin is wrong and
and that's fine but what I saw with
Chase is he starts attacking myin and I
keep seeing all these people attack Myra
and attack the red pillars and call them
degenerates when them in their youth did
the same thing are you too then a
degenerate how are you any different and
what they'll say is I said sorry after I
am different because I said sorry there
was no sense of humility with them none
they are the red pillars are the evil
evil
degenerates and what annoys me about
this was a clip chase this guy that's
going around calling us the evil
degenerates um said that you know myin
is the problem right myON myON myON so
evil because
he slept with the multiple women now if
he wants to say it's immoral
fine but if you're if you're attacking
someone personally and then you're going
on a podcast saying that you did the
same thing two months ago you know it's
one thing it's like okay if you were
imagine if you were a business coach and
you said run your business like I run my
business and they went bankrupt two
months ago you would kind of think huh
and then you would kind of look at their
past and he said he was celibate for
three years so before three years ago
doing the same thing you would look and
you would say huh so he's going bankrupt
every three
years his way isn't working really well
and this is I want to have an honest
conversation with the church about what
I actually see in the church what I see
generally is a bunch of simp men with
overbearing controlling wives that used
to be
hoes
now I do believe in Redemption so what I
am not saying is that God cannot forgive
you for sins what I am not saying is
that women there's no hope for women I
that's not what I'm saying but it it's
kind of like if you guys are selling
religious marriage okay and you're
that's your sell you're saying guys
religious marriage is the
way well we want to look at your wives
and see no kids no Nudes on the internet
no crazy past and I'm sorry guys that is
not what we're seeing and Men naturally
just make a cost benefit analysis that
that's what they naturally do regardless
of what Pearl says regardless of what
anyone says they're going to look at and
see are you getting the results that I
would
want and unfortunately and I wantan to I
want to I want you to not just take my
word for it I actually want to show
you um I want to show
you
a one of the biggest Chastity speakers
and I know them because they came to my
high school so these people have had a
significant impact in the culture okay
they were huge in the Catholic spere and
guys I'm using my religion as an example
and there's way worse religions out
there um Catholics are generally I would
I would argue less corrupt than the rest
not much here this this is humility
right not much but I would say we don't
have you know a freaking band in church
we're not you know it's it's a bit more
scriptural
and even us this is what this is what we
have
okay I'm G to show you simping simping
simping
simping also I'm gonna want look for the
cash apps if if there are any just you
know I want to talk about dating and how
that's is this
2x oh no it's not okay evolved since you
started speaking 20 years ago because
the complaint I often hear you often
hear no doubt I'm sure is women saying
like I don't get asked out or men don't
you know they don't want to date or I
see you know and I know so many
beautiful women in their 20s and their
30s who still aren't married and it's it
can be heartbreaking and I don't mean to
blame this all on the on the dudes but
it's an epidemic because I I think and
when I talk to women are going like I'll
go to a daily mass at noon downtown in
some City while I'm speaking and you see
all these attractive young single
professional women there devout and the
guys aren't anywhere around
the women are amazing it's all the men's
fault see this you go to Catholic Young
Adult Community sometimes and it's you
know 4 to one you know young single
women and uh but why are the men leaving
the church why this is what they're not
talking about it's all on the it's all
on the men always on the men why are
they leaving and I think what's going on
is in China you know they've had this
one child policy for decades and as a
result if you can only have one kid in
China you want a male passes on the
family name the males are esteemed so
much more highly than the women so the
female babies are being aborted at an
exponential rate compared to the male
babies now that this been going on for
enough Generations you have a lot of
single young Chinese males that are
looking for a mate and she's not there
because they were aborted by the
millions and they're looking around and
they're gone I think we're having the
opposite problem in America because of
pornography that men have been
emasculated to such an but why are they
watching it what about these sexless
marriages what about women's high
standards see this is a guy talking that
has very little experience in the dating
scene he doesn't know what's going on
okay exent that the women are reaching a
level of marriage age and maturity and
the guys are 24 but they're 12 years old
emotionally they're still playing their
video games at home they're afraid to
ask a girl out without an app they don't
even know how to ask the girl out and so
the women are looking around like wait a
minute God I'm ready to raise a family
and start having kids and doing this but
where are the decent guys they're hooked
on porn and they're playing video games
and they're just not ready not even not
even a word about women being addicted
to social media here's the funny thing
women are pushing off marriage women
have more control than ever but yet simp
men in the church continue to blame
everything on the men and this whole
conversation 80% of women partake in
some sort of hookup culture 10 maybe 20%
of men do and yet what have been
tradcons been bitching about all week
the men the men the men the men the men
you guys you it drives me crazy okay it
drives me crazy wait did it was the
sound okay was the sound okay one in the
chat if the sound's
okay drives me nuts okay Phillip thank
you very much for the
venmo thank you appreciate you uh let me
check cash app really quick okay we're
all right oh oh and fasil Ley thank you
very much so okay there there's one
example and I'm not done this I'm gonna
go in because I grew up around this
stuff I grew up around this stuff so I
you guys aren't fooling me these people
aren't fooling me so why are men leaving
the
Church all right so nearly 96% there's a
a study asking why young adults are
leaving the church 96% cited Life
Changes including moving to college and
working responsibilities that prevented
them from attending so okay that's one
the second one guess what it was guys
guess what it
was 73% said church or Pastor related
reasons LED them to leave
so like Chase is doing the Hypocrites of
those 32% said church members seem
judgmental or hypocritical
29% said they did not feel connected to
others and I pulled the men on Twitter I
asked them for men that used to be
religious why did you leave that was one
of the biggest
things but you're right guys Pearl's
just making this up I'm just the
evildoer
now again I want to think about this
from the men's point of view does this
sound like a w does this sound like
women like who who are they blaming this
on and let me know in the chat if the
sounds off or
[Music]
anything
and mind you these are the Catholics the
Catholics don't have gay flags yet they
don't have any of that stuff these are
the Catholics everyone okay now I'm
coming from a completely different than
Jason here when I was about a sophomore
in high school I had my first serious
relationship and after a while of dating
we thought we were in love and
everything was great and slowly we
started to get very physical and slowly
the pressure started to set into the
relationship and it came to a point
where he said well girl if you really
love me you truly love me you prove it
to me you show me just how much you love
me so I needed advice so I went to my
girlfriends and I said Well he kind of
wants to do this with me and he wants to
do that and they said well if you aren't
doing this with him all right do you see
already whose fault is it I didn't want
to have sex
I wasn't the one pushing it oh it was
him he said he said if I really loved
him this is what I had to do
like if you wen't doing that bullsh I
just want I just want us to call it what
it is guys that's that's what I get so
irritated about I don't want to play
pretend I just want to call this stuff
what it is you wanted to have sex it
wasn't his fault you wanted to okay
what's wrong with you
everybody's doing it you love him right
and I thought well yeah I love him so at
the age of 15 I lost my virginity
thinking it was going to cause this huge
great emotional bond between us and we'd
be on cloud n and so in love and in all
actuality eventually any love we had in
that relationship was just thrown out
the window because if I couldn't respect
my own body how's he supposed to respect
it and after a while of dating it seemed
like you don't want to spend time with
me anymore he was basically spending the
time with my body and when a person is
being used
okay men want sex silent
sandwiches
I no she doesn't she doesn't talk about
I don't
know the reasons men don't want to get
married they used to get married in
three months a hundred years ago it's
all he's using my body okay they know it
they know it in the depths of their
heart they may deny it they may ignore
it and I Know It And okay see women I'm
G to show you and after a while we were
constantly fighting he was cheating on
me and we went our separate ways now I
will never forget the day when he walked
away from me for the very last time and
as he walked away from me all I could
think about was that guy's taking
something with him that never belonged
to him in the first place but I can't
get it back right what's the point it's
already gone so there I was in the
cafeteria talking with my girlfriend and
I came to this conclusion okay well if a
guy can date me for about six months
without sleeping with me then he must
love me then I'll sleep with him notice
how she's never talked about what she
has to do for
him he's using
me but what I mean we want their
attention so what you're taking
attention from them are they being you
it's just and I think now six months six
months is the price that I put on my
body if he gives me just a little bit of
that time and a little bit of that
attention that's the definition of love
and I Carri this mentality all through
high school he was the first guy but he
wasn't the last and I went down this
vicious cycle and I'm not standing up
here pointing my finger you guys saying
you guys you're the problem it's all
your fault no I happen to believe you
guys will be as much of a gentleman as
we ladies require now I wasn't acting
like a lady back then nor dressing like
a lady back then therefore they didn't
feel the need to rise up and act like a
gentleman around me and what seems to
happen sometimes is that girls will give
guys sex for the sake of getting the
love from them and guys will give girls
the love for the sake of getting the sex
from the girl and it can go both ways
now with this lifestyle I got into the
partying I got into the drinking I got
into the clubbing you name it okay I'm
just saying if you're going to parade
relationship around as the one to be
like again men are going to look at the
product they're going to say is this is
this product
good are most men G to be super excited
to have a wife that's talking about her
ex-boyfriend 15 years
later and talking about her ho escapades
now I know maybe I'm not saying it like
that maybe that we don't like how that
sounds but men are going to look at that
and say huh so if I if I do this church
stuff this is what I
get okay I was into it and Grant at the
time yeah I thought it was a lot of fun
it was very attractive and I know what
that's like but I also know what it's
like to wake up the next day when that
party's over when your friends are gone
and when your there by yourself and I
remember waking up thinking I can't
believe I did that last night I hope I
don't have to see his face in the
hallway at school on Monday what if he
tells everybody what we did all of these
things constantly going through my head
but the night before my friends would
always say oh it's all fun and games
don't worry about it it's not a big
deal it was her friends do you see this
like I just
can't no okay when you [__] up you did
it because you wanted to like ladies
ladies ladies I just I wanna I want to
repeat this okay I did it because I
wanted to I did that and I messed up no
it's not your friend's fault no it's not
your boyfriend's fault maybe it was just
you messed up and this stuff is so
rampant in the church it is always it's
always and and all the tradcon guys that
say they're different are doing the
exact same thing the ex exact same thing
they go in on the women and then they
get pushed back for going too hard on
the women so they're like you know what
now we need to make it even and go in on
the men even though most men are not
partaking tell one girl I know about oh
jeez this is loud okay let me see she's
2 years old had the first memory is her
dad abusing her mom they got divorced he
left the family and he's one of these
guys out there male enough to get a girl
pregnant but not man enough to be a dad
so she's raised with no father she gets
to high school she doesn't know how
gentleman to treat a lady this big
football player asks around they start
dating and then he says her honey I've
never felt this way by a girl before I
love you and for her those words were
magic she never heard that at home and
she said I love you too Reuben he said
if you love me show me she know what
that means do you see it
we these women want to be shown do you
see these guys get bamboozled I'm like
no no no no it was not that these evil
men we pressuring her women like women
are sexual too guys women are sexual too
why was she even in that situation to do
that
stuff I mean in high school you you
could be at your parents house or you
could be alone hanging out in like a I
don't know what a car or
whatever Choice choices choices but they
always put it on the men it's always
always always always always always
always the men's fault and they're so
freaking
annoying and and the thing is guys and
this is my this is my thing to the
men if you are going to prop up your
relationship as the one to be
like it it better be clean otherwise
don't prop it
up you know that that's what I'm saying
otherwise I wouldn't prop it up if I
were you if you're going to go around
calling these guys degenerates
I I would hope you're not engaging in
the degenerate
activity especially when I looked at
Chase's stuff two months
ago like what is crazy people she was a
girlfriend from cafeteria she said Ruben
wants to start doing this and that what
do you guys think they said you like him
right she yeah I like him then they
that's not a big deal everybody's doing
it don't be approved look as long as you
feel ready to get it over with so she
figured yeah it's not a big deal and at
the age of 15 she lost her virginity
thinking they be forever in love she
said in all actuality all respect was
thrown out the window but she said after
a while he didn't want to spend time
with me anymore he maybe he didn't want
to spend time with you because you
weren't Pleasant to be
around I
get everything everything's always
basically spending the time with my body
cuz when a girl is getting used she
knows it she tries to distract okay but
how is is it women like to have sex too
why isn't she using
him it's just nothing nothing is the
woman's so she knows there's no peace he
lost respect for her he start fighting
more cuz every time they're together
it's all he wanted and she gave him sex
for the sake of feeling love you just
give her love for the sake of sex
eventually they broke up she said I will
never forget the day he walked away for
the very last time she said all I can
think to myself is that guy's leaving
with something that never belong in the
first place I'm never going to get it
back not a verion now on the whole point
of waiting for marriage it's too late
for me anyway start of cycle that was
the only honest part he really put in
there you were good at ladies this is
just me being honest it is a tough
cell to ask a guy to wait till marriage
when you were not a
virgin waiting till marri women we only
want 20% of men so if you're actually
attracted to a guy he's top 20%
asking that guy to wait till
marriage when you're not a virgin is a
tough self if you're a virgin okay
different rules
fine tough cell tough sell I mean I I
hope I hope it works out for
you but most men are not going to want
to do that you know
now uh hold on let me pull up the other
ones anyways so again more examples it's
always always always always always hello
hello it's Elizabeth Busby here with a
Theology of hold on always always
always how she met Jason I mean I can go
on but I mean this is just telling their
love story over and over
again yeah again if the man's asking the
woman to wait then she's entering his
frame and you know I I have no problem
if women want to do that I'm just saying
tough cell tough cell okay and then here
we go always what if somebody goes
through the healing process they do the
heavy lifting then you know they didn't
have the best pass then they find that
somebody and they're starting to look
toward marriage and then you know the
details start to come up about their
past and they want to be honest and
transparent um but the partner the
perspective partner is having a real
rough time with this I I I see this a
lot where one person like I waited and I
thought you'd be waiting for me too and
then now we met and I think you're the
one but I don't know how to process your
stuff like do you ever encounter that
with couples and what kind of advice do
you give them to help them to work
through that as a team yeah all all the
time uh that's also very common um I
think two things I think on both sides I
think for the one who's sharing the
story uh there's a lot of vulnerability
in that and it's like what they want and
need is
to be accepted to be to be uh to have
mercy come back instead of judgment and
so they're looking to feel safe enough
to be able to share it they don't want
to stay in hiding they want to be real
and so there's a you know the person
who's okay but there's never uh don't
accept that men you don't have to accept
that it's always man up and marry These
Hoes
always always now I've noticed I've
noticed
they'll always there's always like this
cope and I started writing down the
copes okay does that make sense
everybody what I'm saying with the the
gynocentrism in the church this is
Catholics Christians it's in everywhere
and I know because I argue with you
people on
Twitter
um okay let me go down oh so why are men
leaving the church number one
the Le the quality of wives is not up to
par in the church it's not they go to
the church they see single mothers they
see women with a million red flags and
that and they think well if I'm not
going to get a higher quality wife
here where do I go I've also gotten you
know men tell me that the wife or that
church makes their wife work worse
because they have these women's groups
and in these women's groups all they do
is gossip about their husbands and
they're told they're amazing awesome and
special
247 um on top of
that let's go
here we have hold
on the church has started to look like a
freaking
show men like order and
structure and okay wait when they go to
church and they see
got a handful of grabing umbrella I make
it I make it on
them oh shoot I'm gonna get copyrighted
aren't I dang it okay um but wait here
let me go how do I turn this down this
is too
loud okay
[Music]
um everybody go
I'm sorry is this too loud okay but you
see how the heck oh I turn it down
here sorry guys okay let me
[Music]
go know you know what the enemy did to a
generation that didn't know what to do
with they
bread he made them Make It
[Music]
Rain okay well we're gonna skip I don't
want to copyright he's a counterfeit
right he ain't the first one to make it
rain literally he's not the first one to
make it rain I could take you to
Genesis to prove to you who the first
person was that that made it
rain but scripture said that Mana came
from
heaven and it was bread to
them like what is this [__] this is
supposed to be church I mean and you
know what's so crazy this was from a guy
that was coming at me for not being
Christian enough me pearls just not not
holy enough and that's what they'll do
they'll start they they act exactly like
women they start attacking you
personally you know if I if I criticize
anything about the church then I am not
religious enough if I say that you know
if I disagree with them and I say
cheating doesn't have to be the biggest
of
deals then Pearl is just the evil evil
bad guy okay let's
continue again this is like emotional
all through his ministry people were
trying to trap Jesus the Sadducees and
the Pharisees
and Judas trapped him in the garden and
and and the and the and the the Roman
official get what you'll get in these
churches is it's always like a goodlook
guy pandering to a bunch of women always
always always always and he probably
does the same thing everyone else does
but he's going to go on church to look
really cool and build his brand on God
on the cross but Jesus was and then
usually what he'll do is he'll he'll
talk about things in the church and it's
never anything that will make women feel
bad it's only things that'll make them
feel good they'll talk about all the
shortcomings of the husband and never
any of the shortcomings of the wife
always always always here we go does
this look like mostly men or
women and this is just me
Googling this is just me
Googling Christian preacher
pastors oh a bunch of
women usually their husbands kind of
like walk like
this
okay
um okay the other one and what they'll
do is they'll speak in a very feminine
way they'll
say and they'll just they'll it's soft
and it makes you feel good and God is
coming to save you God is coming to save
you
like
and it's never any real substance and
even people that are not and I'm just
telling you guys I know so many people
that are lukewarm about the church and
the biggest reason they're lukewarm is
this
hypocrisy and you're playing into it
when you go around calling the red
pillars evil degenerates when you did
the exact same thing two months
ago okay now let's see um
um
okay oh you guys nothing is burdening
you down and you've never considered the
fact that you've already got what you
need you've been thinking this is not
enough gifting this is not enough Talent
it's not enough money it's not enough
time I don't have enough and Jesus is
whispering in your ear tonight you got
enough we got these female
pastors all talking like this you are
enough you are special you are amazing
you are so important like if I wanted to
be a
pastor that's what you have to
do don't listen to that you always need
to have a bad guy right so don't listen
to those evil people over there you you
are special and important and amazing
and and God will save you and that's it
boom boom I could it's so like and I
guys I don't know how I how to describe
it but there is something innate when
you can just feel that someone's full of
[__] and a lot of these pastors they
literally think they're God's chosen one
I swear they do I I they'll tell you
that
they and they get such a holier than
thou high
horse
that they they don't even see how big of
Hypocrites they are and again if they're
talking about what's a sin and what's
not a sin that's one thing but when you
start saying the evil degenerate red
pillars when your solution is to go to
church and get a sorry get a born again
home okay sorry I'm sorry guys
okay um let me show you the other
[Music]
one I need water but I want to get up
okay all right so I asked the men I
asked the me oh yeah
um now again if we're gonna go talk
about hookup culture guys there should
be 10 sermons about women's MCU before
there is one on men because the majority
of women partake in hookup culture the
majority of men do not so crying about
the top 10% of men that get to screw all
the chicks is a waste of time they're
going to do it they have always done it
and 50% of pastors admit to having
emotional Affairs so even if you're
going to sell or sorry emotional or
physical Affairs even if you're going to
sell you're going to say hey
high value men come to our
church they'll say okay what do you have
to offer me do you have wives well no we
have some okay they'll say all right um
well what do you what do you have to
offer me do you
have are you
gonna are we going to talk about the
things that matter they're like no we're
just going to shame you for sleeping
around they're like okay what what what
did they get from going to the church
Church what what do they get
now this is not me hating on religion
this is not being being anti- God
they're trying to paint me as anti-god
I'm like are you people insane you are
more dramatic than these hoes that I've
had on my show the past year oh my gosh
so all because I say hey cheating's
different for men and for women you
should probably just get over it if your
husband
cheats call me crazy
um they're going to say okay if I go to
your church if I go to your
church is it going to be structured
they'll go into the church they'll look
around and they see these concerts they
say
okay what do men what do high value men
get out of following your religion and
before you go around trying to fix the
world's problems maybe try to fix your
own church because most of your churches
are moving in the liberal Direction in
the last 10 20 years I have not seen a
church that is getting more traditional
and more conservative I haven't seen it
I haven't seen it um even I know people
in traditional catholic communities very
rigid and the way the world's going is
more
liberal
so I I don't make the world that I live
in I'm not saying this is the way I want
it to go but my biggest criticism is
again tradcons will always find a way to
blame everything on the men and you have
bigger problems than 10% of men cheating
there are bigger problems to talk about
so I asked the men um why they left the
church I put this on Twitter feel free
to put your
experience um all right so one
disillusion brought on by breathtaking
hypocrites the pastor's wife was banging
the youth pastor the junior Pastor was
swapping wives with one of the Elder
tingles trumps Dogma we are implored to
be
righteous um after a long story to after
a long period of time you realize no one
knows what's going on and the behavior
of the people in the church is usually
in opposite to their beliefs I'm
agnostic but strongly suspect there's an
afterlife or simulation I don't want it
confined to a
religion
this isn't the way I want it to go but
this is what's happening and I'm showing
you guys why so if you want this take
the Christ pill if you want to do all
this you guys got to fix your churches
before fixing the world and you guys
will go out and you'll evangelize and
preach but nothing will
change until you get successful
competitive men in the church and right
now I look at most churches it's a bunch
of datas that mared de hoes and blame
everything on the men always okay um let
me see if there was anything else I was
going to go over um okay like here this
guy Mike
Foster again this is sing this is
absolute sing is a marriage is getting
married a risk yes the danger of
divorcing corrupt family law must not be
downplayed is getting not getting
married at risk yes
but the cost of not having spousal
companionship virtuous sex or potential
Flesh and Blood Legacy might not must
not be
downplayed
okay so I want to tell you guys a
story so I work with a organization that
helps men get access to their children
and that's that's what they mainly do
all they try to do is help men get in
contact with their
kids um and there is a guy at one of
these
organizations um that I work with and he
tells me every month he has men that
kill
themselves
constantly um and one story he told me
was there was a guy
that his wife said that he touched the
children the entire community Community
thought that he was a
pedo he lost all of his
money his
legacy his kids were being raised with
an evil woman and he shot himself in the
face he was
found not guilty of
this and um like before anyways it was
in Family Court not criminal court
but his rep reputation was that of one
that touched
children getting zeroed out is not
uncommon it happens a lot it is not a
fringe case that case might be Fringe
but it is not uncommon for a guy to get
zeroed out it is not uncommon for men um
to have their entire reputations
ruined um to lose the access to their
children to have their kids hate
them um so why why don't tradcon say
change the laws first if you really want
traditionalism to come back men will
look at the costs of something and
they'll look at the benefits and right
now the benefits of women are
low you don't get a
virgin they're paid to
leave many have had abortions many have
reinvented them like the costs are the
benefits are going lower and the costs
keep going higher it becomes riskier and
riskier every day until you fix the
system men will stop getting married
regardless of what anybody puts on
Twitter um let's see if there's another
one I wanted to respond
to
you
know when I
started this stuff I didn't know why men
feared
marriage but guys if when you have seen
what I've seen and you've interviewed
the amount of men that I have
interviewed and seen
like I have never seen more and I don't
know how to describe it but it's like
death in a guy's eyes
when his kids are down the street from
him and he can't see them there is one
man who ex-wife was dating a
guy that had been convicted of touching
kids and there was nothing he could do
because that guy had already served his
time and he was in the house with his
daughter some of this stuff is hell to
men and the tradcons say oh just wave It
Off
buckle up get married anyway and they
have no idea what they have they are
talking about go to Family Court I don't
want to hear about anything until you
guys have actually gone to Family Court
none of them have so go do it spend a
day you people will not take the Christ
pill until you fix the
system and I do not blame men for
adapting if men can't live without sex
sex is a need for men and they choose to
just screw hose for a lifetime because
they look at that system and say I don't
want to risk my reputation I don't want
to
see I understand that and I I I don't
blame
them and what they'll say is they'll say
the men are are submitting to feminism
most men have normal jobs most men are
not in
politics there are
billionaires that can't fix the system
it's not as easy as just just fix it go
fix it there's people that have been
working
50 50 years can't fix the
system it's not that
simple
um and okay I want to
do and the truth of the matter is we are
actually in a post-marriage world
marriage has not existed for 50 plus
years when birth control came in and no
fault divorce we no longer have marriage
you have a system that pays women to
leave that's what you have it's not
marriage and it can't be marriage
because it's only marriage until she
feels like it's
not and what I'll see is I'll see
religious people coping when you say
marriage is
dead they'll find a religious Niche a
very Fringe religious Niche and say well
if only the men prayed every day then
their wife wouldn't leave
them I I saw a study it was from the 70s
and they said couples don't divorce or
maybe 80s if they pray every
day so now the guys have to pray every
day in order to not get divorced every
day can't like take a day off
off and they still find a way to blame
it on the men oh if he only prayed
praying will not save you from a scorned
woman no it will not and you need to
warn men about this stuff because many
have no idea what they're signing up
for
okay they'll claim that we're just
making this up I get gas lit oh that's
just your
church I've lived around the world it's
it's consistent across across the
world I've lived in different countries
grew up with nannies from around the
world
okay they'll Point po point to their
marriage as the success story which
generally is Born Again virgins
okay generally controlling
wives
generally women that don't follow their
husband it's a happy wife happy life
type relationship
if they do have a virgin wife what I
found is usually there's no way to
verify that they didn't know them when
they were growing
up I mean so we're really just going
based off of her
word and then what they'll do is they'll
try to make the stats better so they'll
say well first marriages have a lower
divorce rate you're more likely to
succeed in a first
marriage but what they don't do is they
discount that we have a society that
tells on itself with the reputation of
those marriages we have cheaper to
keeper type marriages happy wife happy
life women that publicly berate their
husbands um and they'll try to spin it
as a 75% success rate they don't talk
about the women that get fat they don't
talk about the women
um that nag their husbands constantly
they'll they'll try to sell marriage as
a 50 75% success rate and they also
don't take into account the fact that
many women the women of today are
different than yesterday we have had
social media since we were 12 years old
that affects women we have had a ton of
attention from the time that we were
young and sometimes the tradcons tell on
themselves because they miss the point
women are women regardless of if you go
to another country regardless of if you
go to your church regard like it does
not matter women or women there are some
better some worse but women still have a
nature um and it's evil yeah anyways
last one because I I have to go to
volleyball
soon we're GNA talk about or I'm gonna
show Charlie Kirk sing because I just
need to talk about do you think that
people who procure abortion okay I just
need to talk about these
simps I can't take it any longer I can't
okay women specifically a woman who
procures an abortion should go to jail
for getting one absolutely yeah they're
the moral equivalent of aitz really yes
um mil millions of women are are
basically the same as like Nazi the
women are victims they're lied to 90% of
women do not see an ultrasound before
they have an abortion they have no idea
what's happening to them they are the
victims here Google
it Charlie Charlie I'm sorry if I am
going to get a procedure
done Google it you can't Google what
happens in an
abortion if I if I women will Google the
plastic surgeon they get their bbl's
Botox and whatever else from they can't
Google what an abortion
is and so it's not their fault because
the internet doesn't this is
simping simp simp simp simp simp and
it's all
because they don't want to hold women
accountable because they have these
tradcon female bases and if they go in
too hard on women it makes them look bad
and that's all they want they want
followers they want all this stuff
instead of just being
honest why would a woman not go to jail
if I if I hired a Hitman and maybe I
didn't know how okay let's just say I
hired a hitman I hired a Hitman to
kill somebody all right let's just say
and that
guy pulled the guy's limbs off one by
one and then and then stabbed him and I
said but I thought you were just GNA
shoot
him would you have said oh well you know
what Pearl you didn't know you shouldn't
go to
jail do dear God make it stop make the
sing stop I can't watch it any longer it
is the abortionists that are doing this
but let me ask you and I mean this have
you guys ever seen an abortion on a
video I'm sorry if women are the victims
here why should they be jailed well I
don't believe they should be jailed I
think said the
abortion believe that abortion is murder
but a murderer shouldn't go to jail I
didn't say that the doctors the abor I
mean did he just get schooled by a
he just
lost okay simpery simpery has just made
one of the greatest
Debaters
lose oh my gosh this is hilarious the
people that call themselves doctors the
people that put women under general
anesthesia and go
into but they take
it
do they ask they are doctors they're
medical are you going to just discount
the accountability of my current
perspective is because the women are not
given what is called informed consent
okay wait I just want to show I just
want to show Charlie something okay I
just I just want to show him just in
case he didn't know okay so if I was
going to get I'm not so please don't
clip it and make it look weird okay if I
said how to
get an abortion or video watch this
watch this watch this video of a
abortion oh my God is that
Google is
that but you're right yeah yeah just put
it on the men yeah it's just the men's
fault as
usual you know else is crazy they're
talking about the men that are sleeping
around but they don't talk about the
women do you know I swear if we had to
go to monogamy straight monogamy women
would be the ones that would break it
first they would be begging to be a side
chick if you take side chick if you
don't let side chicks be side chicks
they will be devastated okay that's the
first women women will come back and say
please please let me be a side chick I
want to sleep with Drake I want to sleep
with future please please let me back in
if if they went to the men and said you
evil men one woman for life do you know
who would break it first freaking women
women women women women women women go
go to any Rock concert do you know who's
throwing thems it's not the the evil men
the evil men at Drake's concert just
Drake's going out and saying women
please sleep with me no it's the women
it's the women saying please please take
us take us please and it's like the
tradcon will'll say oh but she was just
young she didn't know what she was doing
and then you'll look at like a
18-year-old chick or 19-year-old chick
and she's like I want to do that one
please take me please oh
please I just can't I can't deal with
the simpery I just want the simpery to
die that's what I want I want the
simpery to go away okay you know the
victims here why should they be jailed
well I don't believe they should be
jailed I think the the abortion
believe abortion is murder but a
murderer shouldn't go to jail I didn't
say that the doctors the abortionists
the people that call themselves doctors
the people that put women under general
anesthesia and go into women do they ask
they are doctors they're medical are you
going to just discount theability of my
current perspective is because the women
are not given what is called informed
consent that the women should not be
penalized would you say abortion is
murder okay what is informed
consent they know they're killing a kid
okay like but this is why guys women
have always killed their children this
idea that women are more
nurturing I don't believe it for a
second that's just women running their
marketing schemes to make us seem more
special and important and awesome than
we are if we're more n nurturing why do
we kill kids after they're born we're
the most likely ones to kill the kids
after they're born in the first year of
Life men never do it we're also the most
likely ones to kill the elderly
who is the more violent sex the one that
goes against the freaking
innocent the innocent
okay
now then they'll just say the evil men
the evil men the evil evil evil evil men
and I just can't I can't take this sing
I can't take you tradcons talking for a
week about how 10% of men are screwing
women women know damn well what they're
getting into they're not these innocent
creatures that are just Bamboozled and
have no idea what's going on stop it
stop it stop it stop it stop it I can't
I can't deal I can't deal and um one of
the tradcons decided that he was going
to investigate my family because we
have a different
opinion on
cheating this is the level level of of
Christianity these guys push okay um you
know I don't bring in his family to it
quite quite rude quite I'm just saying
quite
quite quite
rude and these guys will do this under
the guise of being
these Christianity so this is my thing
this is my plea to the Christians all
right fix your churches figure out get
rid of the you have only figured out how
to get simp men in the church you have
not figured out how to get the actual
actual masculine men that women want in
the church and until you figure out how
to get them back in the church you will
keep
losing you will keep losing the culture
will still go one way the church is
still going to be feminized because all
you have is simps in the church you're
going to keep marrying these Born Again
hoes and the men with the option to not
do that are just going to say I'm going
to bow out I'm going to just not be
religious and the number one reason that
they're going to give on their way out
is
hypocrisy so I don't
know I'm not a preacher do you think
that I'm not a preacher I just give my
opinions you can take it or leave it you
know let me know let me know what you
guys think could the Cobbetts uh like
the video on your way out and please let
me I think there was a couple cash apps
I'm going to get to them
all right Phillip oh I read his Charles
Silva says I really appreciate your
honesty and all the problems you talk
about within the church which are real
come
from incorrect dot dot dot I guess I
guess I'll find out one day what the dot
dot dot
is I don't know
okay one second
guys thank you fasil Loi and
pearl um from Matthew
malalo yeah thank you guys for the for
the cash app super chats if you're
rewatching this later feel free to send
send some money as we are demonetized
like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next